bonne anniversaire tintin le héros jeune
reporter à la houppette né sous la plume
de hergé fête aujourd'hui même ses 70
ans à succès inégalé plus de 200
millions d'albums vendus même au tibet
est traduite dans 58 lang pierre
emmanuel luneau dans la grande famille
des rejets certaines créations sont
toujours restés dans l'ombre quelques
pannes passionnés arrive parfois à
dénicher des trésors mais les occasions
sont rares et surtout cher le tout
premier album d'hergé tintin au pays des
soviets était jusque là introuvable
il vient d'être réédité il faut dire
qu'au fil des pages l'album se révèle
violemment anti communiste en fait ce
fut le patron des rg à l'époque qui lui
dicte après ce que le scénario hergé se
trouve un petit peu réduit à devoir
faire d'illustration de texte et malgré
ce caractère d'illustration de textes de
textes anti-communistes il arrive à
introduire ce qu'on pourrait appeler une
pensée originale par les images de fêtes
ce premier album regorge déjà de grande
réussite graphique et de trouvailles
qu'il utilisera tout au long de son
oeuvre
hergé fera même preuve d'une certaine
distance avec son ancien patron
l'abbé wallez dans la première case de
l'album c'est à lui que tintin fait ses
adieux
quelques années plus tard rg change le
scénario dans l'album suivant qui est un
terreau congo rg va mettre en scène dans
la première case les
les au revoir de tintin mais cette
fois-ci tintin ne va pas dire au revoir
à l'abbé vallès tintin va dire au revoir
un petit groupe de personnages parmi
lesquels surtout en reconnaît hergé
lui-même après ce titre
hergé ne laissera plus personne
s'approprier son héros 22 albums
suivront tintin au pays des soviets
une épopée qui nous aura accompagnés
durant tout le siècle